l'eau de la baie de fundy est à 4 degrés
celsius
rien pour empêcher michel cormier dit
plongé depuis 1992 il est mordu de
plongée sous marine
j'étais comme andré rouquet donc tous
les hivers on revenait en 92
il y avait presque personne qui vient
ici
aujourd'hui ils sont une dizaine sur la
plage de saint georges près de dix
heures and diane et serge cornut billets
ter d'une école de plongée remarque eux
aussi l'intérêt grandissant
non seulement pour la plongée mais pour
pêcher le mollusque le des hommes mais
des personnes des plongeurs qui vont
appeler la prochaine plongée de béton
que vous allez faire
est ce qu'on voit avec 12 euros puis on
les a avec vous dire de nouveaux
plongeurs qui sont venus aujourd'hui
au début tu seras dans l'eau louis
allées froides aussi chaud qu'au début
la première pétanque qui trouvait
t'oublie tout le mal qu'il se ramasse ça
fait des belles pêches
parmi les pétoncles se trouvent
notamment au sein des étoiles de mer un
véritable spectacle sous marins à chaque
fois qu'on vient on se surprend pas on
en trouve pour l'en trouve aujourd'hui
en auvergne ou non informé notre côté on
a un permis sans fait tant par jour un
plongeur la pêche récréative au pétoncle
existe depuis plus de 100 ans
mais ce n'est que depuis le milieu des
années 80 qui les réglementent et les
demandes de permis sont stables depuis
cinq ans autour de 1500 contrairement à
d'autres espèces les stocks de pétanque
sont en très bonne santé en atlantique
et selon pêches et océans canada il n'y
aurait pas de tensions entre des
pêcheurs commerciaux et les amateurs
et une fois à l'extérieur de l'eau
l'expérience visuelle devient aussi
gustatives à la grosse tête c'est bon
une livre des plus gros pétanque peut se
vendre jusqu'à 28 $ en poissonnerie
ce soir c'est la femme de michel
profitera avec lui de sa récolte à soir
je pars probablement de fou avec un peu
de big n qui peut-être même un petit peu
de sirop d'érable délicieux s'il accepte
de donner sa recette
michel reste cependant secret sur ses
autres repères de pêche et simonon temps
beau radio-canada saint georges